in time
mayné mi sebastián marroquín forms like
pablo escobar there are healthy before pablo
escobar
living life football money los power
[Music]
my father the time vivos pero bueno de
richter
colombia
[Music]
berlin
imagine
organization
los charts
[Music]
we  we were living in life whitfield power
english
[Music]
victor becali i live to ride that's why i
was waiting
joey go with gilberto be in 2006 the
same in money and economic and fire in
best work for in two laws of physics
for lines my dear me something in  Escobar
will probably leave the states Pablo
Escobar wanted to control the distribution
of cocaine on the streets of the United States,
mainly New York,
so there was a dispute over
distribution in New York between the
people of Cali, in between
Calicanto and only from Medellín Cartel
roots in New York and  that make my
father
of health and wellness set they must be
hacking from the spirit fundal that there is to
leave a blank in the universe  so of action
marco town yuppies édgar beach 10 and
rooms tango and technician from nasa study
engineering and care when going war game
square
pablo what he did was lock us up in
apartments for years so that
we forgot to see the light of the
sun and so  protect us
[Music]
as a copy of that family with this
book what i start to be our
consequences my father's actions what
is the effort
and you for
fidel i was in
monaco that night i
saw that there were people in another
building who did not forget
and  They imagined that I was in the
room with Pablo
around four thirty to five in
the morning I was already sleeping with me
[Music]
and I imagined that there had been
an earthquake
I start to hear the screams of my
children
Sebastián begins to  cry to say mom
I'm drowning help me save me I
start to move and I look up and I
realized that I'm homeless in my
room
[Music
] I mean I went out in my pajamas with my  s
sons looked around all
the buildings were destroyed half the
neighborhood was wiped out by the bomb it
was crazy
50 kilos of dynamite caused a
more impressive explosion than has been
reported in the valley of aburrá there are two
people dead five injured and
material losses could  rising to
ten billion pesos
in my father even more president birdie it
was almost for good addressing the heat
family it smells really good Pablo got angry
he became like a panther but he
focused on how to continue a war or how to
collect that damage that to us  they
had made us
[Music]